Once upon a time in London, there was a lovely girl named Wendy.
She was reading stories to her brothers, John and Michael.
"A long long time ago, there lived Peter Pan in Neverland."
Wendy and her brothers liked the story.
Suddenly Wendy's dog, Nana, barked out the window.
There was a boy dressed in green.
"Who are you?"
"My name is Peter Pan and this is my special friend, Tinkerbell."
"Hello! Nice to meet you!"
Peter Pan and Tinkerbell flew around the room showing off tricks.
"Wow, great!"
"Are you really Peter Pan?"
"Yes, I'm from Neverland. It's the island of dreams."
"Wow, you are a real boy! That's amazing!"
"I have always dreamed of Neverland."
"Do you want to come to Neverland?"
"Yes! But what about Michael and John? I want to go with them."
"Of course they can come."
"Yeah! Let's go!"
Tinkerbell sprinkled magic dust on the children, and they began to fly.
"Wow, fantastic!"
"Whee!"
They all shouted.
Wendy, Michael and John flew to Neverland with Peter Pan.